[Music]
in multi-purpose car news submitted by
cheap shoes an increasing number of
Japanese people are renting cars for
everything but driving driving instead
of driving yeah oh no no for me I was
thinking like but you just only drive so
what do they use it for the photo shoot
these [ __ ] and they're living
in them yeah eating in there I don't
know no that all win dashboard so car
rental operators in Japan are saying
that there's this weird new trend that
they've noticed that the cars that are
being rented have very unusually low
mileage so it seems as though these
people that are renting these cars are
barely driving or not driving it at all
so what they did is that they sent out a
survey to find out what people are using
these cars for and so some people said
that they were using them to eat and in
their car or like for example this one
time there was this woman who needed to
store some luggage and like away but all
the lockers at the train station were
taken so she ended up storing it at the
truck trunk of the car or this other guy
like he usually takes a nap when he goes
to visit his clients and a bad salesman
probably they did right everything's
like hey what's up Jeff it's like I love
seeing my clients and taking a nap yep
so instead of napping at a cyber cafe in
front of the station they decided to
rent a car which is like almost the same
as staying as the cyber cafe and then
not cheap Oh cuz cars here around are
[ __ ] expensive tuner books flat but
there's a lot of apps out there that you
could just like telling Zipcar oh yeah
you could just get a car that way that's
why they're saying that they don't even
move them sometimes because they just
want the cart so like just like a
sitting like a just their own like a pod
such a lack of space I think they just
like that's need a place to do something
I wish they would raise the prices for
the [ __ ] bird scooters because there
every goddamn where and he just drop
them in the middle of street someone
fall over from the wind and hit a car
apart I was like what do I do
and I didn't do anything well that you
were I was gonna no wonder my spear I
was gonna even know and be like hey if
you want to with a huge [ __ ] dent on
your side door as a bird scooter but I
didn't I don't want to insert myself
bird scooters the others say that they
were also working meat eaters nice calm
thing to like just talk on the phone
with friends mmm
or have like meetings with their
business partners white people's we're
hanging out in the car did you still got
space coffee shops are small
everything's small especially if it's
cheap - like if it's like 20 bucks and
then they can just spend the you know
whole time in that car like that's
prospective than sitting in a public
space yeah cuz privacy is really hard to
get in Japan well mainly in Tokyo in
public especially that's true but
everyone be mining on business in Japan
yeah yeah that's true yeah this is just
a very strange trend that's are they mad
about it or do they not care well they
do they would like people to drive the
car because the more mileage like you
charge more yeah they're like double a
car rental service so there's like stop
using this car for not the purpose of
maybe they should charge if they don't
hit a certain mile but then that's gonna
dick to do that's so dick geo you're so
corporate you used to be one of us
you're right guys corporate geohash that
corporate to you I don't know who I am
anymore
no but that's just dumb it's a business
they're gonna go out of business cuz
these [ __ ] aren't using it for the
way it is [ __ ] you business a car
because people are hanging out in the
car too much because they can't charge
any one hand for the [ __ ] thing I
think I don't know how these work
because I don't think I don't know if I
got charged for miles here so I don't
know how it works they use that to fill
the tank up for whatever that's all I
remember
no there is a mileage I mean you're not
supposed to go over a certain mile like
you pay for like a bundle yeah yeah cuz
if you drive from here all the way to
like I don't know next car
Ensenada or something then walk over
yeah Mexico yeah and then you come all
the way back and yeah they should charge
you for that cuz it's
and tear on the car yeah maybe I just
don't know maybe they gave it to you
because I like Vegas or like San
Francisco and then that's a long it's
like a hundred miles or maybe you didn't
pay attention you got money like that
the range is pretty big though it's like
250 miles a day or something like that
oh I guess when you're renting a car
you're doing it like gold somewhere
that's right so expenses like the
baseline is already this much like go
ahead take it away go drive anywhere you
want because you're already gonna cost
this much one of those egg cars though
those really small ones they're like 30
bucks a day or something well now you
have Turo you have an asset literally
someone will come in bring a car to
wherever you are being before your car
yeah and it's like 70 bucks or 24 hours
to get a van someone could literally
just like sleep in the back of a van and
not pay a hotel room dude the rain is
too damn high I'd be sitting do you
remember being like um tooth damp
underage and be like oh man you gotta be
like 23 or in a car and I'm like oh that
sucks
so jaws the today's teens I'm like you
call him but the pencil in Cobras is it
did you see book-smart
what's that we watch I know the other
dumb movie the anti inside or something
right or price right burn we watch that
stupid ass movie and book smart it's
supposed to be like a portrait of
today's tease and they take ubers ever
the whole night so remember super bad
that movie yeah I think they're like
walk in the make up these car to drive
them instead all these problems are
solved because these teen girls are just
like boo boo yeah you feel that everyone
is like 15 15 15 year thought about 30
no under 16 to 13 junior high Bobby not
okay but high school I was I was Prince
of where he eats and if you're right it
does depend where like piano lessons I'd
be like let me do it on my off and what
city on it I don't have to [ __ ] move
and you can go move for yourself sports
kids had 10 something next to Arcadia
high school the other day I was driving
I was like it's late you've got your
high school kids need to be home this
all got to be a nine-year-old kid out at
9:30 at night and this is how I know I'm
closer to being a parent than I am to
being a kid I was like what are they
doing out at night ridiculous how deep
can you make your voice very nice
I can go this long that sounds like Tay
Zonday that's good
you see chocolate rings hello Steve how
have you been oh yeah every time I see
Taylor Oh
Steve it's nice to see ya
for some weird reason if you type in my
name the first thing that comes up is
Chocolate Rain I always like to say this
to people because I know him I always
like to say oh you know Adam and then
the trace people are like what did they
entail on day out there for a while it's
very strange
how'd you even find out are you kept
googling yourself yeah it's got a
podcast
oh really anybody should have a podcast
he has he had that radio vents though
yep I want to hear your high pitched go
ha ha ha yeah what a range of guys I'm
sorry I can't go any higher I don't want
to punch my dick you don't want to come
in you got so high that I stopped
hearing you well that's how I get dogs
attention in public when I say really
kilo [ __ ] fluffernutter and I wanted
to look at me I just go oh my god
children let me touch your dog in public
geo thinks that if you punch a dude in
the dick it's like [ __ ] home-along
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you gotta lay down yeah you
can't even talk you can't even breathe
no I used to [ __ ] kick dudes in the
dick in high school like my thing oh
that's a good thing bullied a lot I
would get made fun of for not having
titties the guy walked up to me that's
their dicks and they would say you go if
you don't have feet would you wear socks
and I was like no and you goes the why
do you wear bra okay initially I thought
I was just for no reason no I got you on
sir well I thought you're like that's my
thing like hi I'm Kelsey
or people like that for sure yeah but
what's kicking guys on the deck not a
thing when you guys were in an
elementary school I wasn't bullied you
were like I was I know I wasn't
I think cuz I'm Paul I just wasn't
bullied No did you get laid no getting
laid I was like what actually that
Carolyn you look it with you in natural
beauty girls like me hate girls like you
could wake up and look like that
see and that's why I got bullied there
you go she had a tough two you know hot
girls having to talk to no I was showing
you pictures of my high school I was
[ __ ] disgusting oh that's like my
wife she was pretty wrecked in high
school yeah I think it'll matter what I
don't know anyone that hasn't got
bullies yeah I got bullied at home like
yeah more it was pretty busted I'm not
special thanks guys yeah you're not
unique you're not a snowflake
I just get bullied I'm like well that's
why this sparkling personality came from
because I was like well I'm not the hot
chick and I'm clear that the liked chick
with did so I gotta be funny a really
good at beer pong and boy am i are you
really good at beer pong the best wow
wow don't you wish that you did another
sport that maybe pays my plum no because
you know I got dick down when I was in
college came in handy eventually that's
pretty my tits never came in though
don't worry guys don't really care about
piss that much not anymore I'm all about
that ass I've always been about the hair
that's energy but I thought cities all
day I would ask them titties I do this
but if I had to choose yep isn't it true
the same thing about a vagina like I
feel like girls are always so worried
about what their labias look like I've
never even thought about that and guys
are like my boyfriend was the one who
said I mean either I was always like you
get [ __ ] like you were [ __ ] welcome
I thought they all look the same yeah
and my boyfriend was like no guy has
ever been like that pussy's not perfect
so I'm not gonna [ __ ] it it's like
I don't care like it's like a birthday
party I'm happy to be here that's
literally what it is yeah it's like a
book it's all you girls out there
worried about the wrong [ __ ] yeah don't
be a [ __ ]
don't worry about you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]